John: Gooood Morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
Wait, it's Tuesday.
That means that I am no longer for the United
States.
I am now all in for Mexico!
Hank, as you know I am auctioning off my World
Cup support for Sarcoma research - link in
the doobly-doo.
Every time you donate $1, I donate 3, and
in total we've now raised more than $55,000
to fight Sarcoma, which is so awesome.
Hey, why are you only gesticulating with one
hand?
Well, funny story...
So Hank, as you know I am a retired semi-professional
FIFA player.
For years, I uploaded my FIFA videos to YouTube,
people watched them, advertising revenue,
etc.
But a while ago, I decided to retire from
professional FIFA playing because I'm older
now and the physical and emotional strain
had just gotten to be too much.
I decided I had to play just for the love
of the game, for the love of the pixels.
So all the money we make now goes to an actual
football club, AFC Wimbledon, owned by its
fans, the first football club to come out
against homophobia in England; they're just
amazing.
Right, okay Hank, so if you're like me and
you're not actually very good at FIFA it's
not enough to like press the joystick in the
right directions and hit the right buttons.
You have to create a loving, supportive environment
for your team made of pixels so that they
feel comfortable scoring.
Now for me a big part of that is yelling at
the screen, sometimes like pulling this way
when I want them to go that way, but it also
involves some singing, and then when they
score, I want to celebrate with them!
All of this is to say, Hank, that recently,
the AFC Wimbledon Wimbly Womblys scored a
goal so beautiful, so amazing that I did what
any manager would do: I shot up my arms and
I shouted, "AFC Wimbledon!"
Only I did it with both arms, because that
was back when I could move both of my shoulders.
That's right Hank, I shot my right arm into
the air after scoring a goal in a video game
and seriously injured my shoulder.
How seriously?
Not yet clear, waiting for some test results.
How do you injure yourself playing a video
game?!
Actually, no, I did not injure myself playing
a video game.
I injured myself celebrating my success playing
So yeah, Hank, this whole experience has made
me realize something: I'm old.
I have a lot of gray hair over here, but in
the two months of promoting The Fault in Our
Stars movie I got a lot of new gray hair up
in here.
Now Hank, thankfully you're not old and, as
far as I can tell, you never will be.
You have the body of a man in his 30's, but
the personality and face of an excited 9-year-old,
which I mean as a compliment.
So Hank, hopefully you'll be the brother who
doesn't get old and, like, stays hip and cool,
but Nerdfighters, I am getting old.
In fact, I'm older than I was when I started
this video.
I'm having a little bit of a crisis about
being old because I wanna be a Nerdfighter
for the rest of my life, so I'm hoping there
are other old Nerdfighters.
I think there are.
But mostly I just wanted to say I hope we
can still be friends even though I am old
and shoulder-less.
Again, link in the doobly-doo to our World
Cup fundraiser.
You can follow along the World Cup with me
at my sports Twitter, @sportswithjohn.
Hank, don't play video games too strenuously.
I will see you on Friday.